madame la ministre je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation votre
ministère est au cœur de la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique et la
transition
énergétique en constitue à l'évidence le
fer de lance nous traversons
actuellement une période de crise
énergétique avec une forte tension sur
les prix les conséquences pour nos
concitoyens et les acteurs économiques
sont certes élevés mais il faut saluer
votre action
action qui a permis de prendre des
mesures qui s'imposaient pour atténuer
les effets cette situation constitue
aussi une incitation forte à poursuivre
notre transition vers une économie
décarbonée et sobre dans l'usage des
ressources naturelles c'est une exigence
pour le climat et pour les générations
futures c'est une nécessité pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens notre souveraineté
énergétique et la compétitivité de nos
entreprises cette transition implique
donc des changements profonds de nos
comportements et c'est tout l'objet du
plan de sobriété énergétique que vous
présenterez
demain nous serons attentifs à ces
annonces qui d'ailleurs mobilisent notre
commission depuis plusieurs semaines
madame la ministre vous nous présenter
un budget d'action il consacre un
montant sans précédent en chaque énergie
traduit dans les faits des engagements
pris lors de la Coop 27 de Glasgow en
supprimant les garanties à l'export pour
les opérations portant sur le charbon et
les hydrocarbures et il augmente
notamment les crédits de ma prime rénov
je vous laisserai bien entendu le soin
de présenter l'ensemble de ces mesures
puis bien sûr nous serons très
intéressés par les éclairages que vous
pourriez nous apporter sur le projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable texte
d'importance sur lequel nous souhaitons
que notre Commission soit pleinement
impliquée nous avons d'ailleurs créé une
mission flash sur cette problématique ce
texte
mais en lumière la nécessité de
concilier trois enjeux très importants
des enjeux forts à la fois le soutien à
la transition
énergétique en facilitant le déploiement
de projet d'énergie renouvelable pour
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
deuxième enjeu la préservation du
patrimoine naturel et la biodiversité et
troisième enjeu la participation du
public pour les projets ayant une
incidence sur l'environnement comme le
prévoit la Charte de l'environnement
madame la ministre comment pensez-vous
concilier ces trois enjeux très
importants pour notre commission je ne
serai pas plus long madame la ministre
je vous cède la parole puis nous
passerons aux échanges avec les députés
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés je
vous remercie l'organisation de cette
audition sur les priorités de mon
ministère en matière de politique
énergétique et sur son budget pour
l'année 2023 vous le savez nous vivons
une crise énergétique sans précédent
probablement plus marqué que celle que
nous certains d'entre nous ont connu
dans les années 70 et les experts sont
formels nous n'avons plus que trois ans
pour inverser la tendance en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique quand je dis trois ans ça
vaut évidemment pour la planète puisque
vous le savez la France diminue déjà ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre cela
nous impose de revoir en profondeur
notre mode de consommation et de
production d'énergie avec une double
temporalité l'urgence de l'hiver
prochain et de l'hiver d'après et la
nécessité d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050
et ne nous trompons pas l'attente de la
neutralité carbone suppose des décisions
au moins aussi urgentes que le passage
de l'hiver 2022 2023 plus largement
au-delà de son impact climatique notre
politique énergétique emporte des enjeux
de souveraineté économiques et
politiques et je crois que la guerre en
Ukraine se charge de nos rappeler chaque
matin et des enjeux de pouvoir d'achat
pour les Français tout comme des enjeux
de compétitivité pour les entreprises
dans ce contexte la feuille de route que
m'a confié le président de la République
m'ont confié le président de la
République et la première ministre est
très clair il s'agit de devenir la
première grande nation industrielle à se
passer des énergies fossiles et à
atteindre la neutralité carbone
or aujourd'hui deux tiers de notre
consommation d'énergie et d'origine
fossiles et importés 2/3 et je veux
dissiper ce mythe que nous aurions été à
un moment de notre histoire autonome
énergétiquement cela n'a jamais été le
cas notre programme électronucléaire
vous le savez a permis de réduire une
partie de notre dépendance mais celle-ci
reste majeure en particulier pour les
transports et la chaleur
notre feuille de route ma feuille de
route repose sur quatre leviers ils sont
pas très originaux ce sont ceux des
experts en matière énergétique en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et qui s'intéresse à la
question de la souveraineté il s'agit de
la sobriété de l'efficacité énergétique
d'une part de la production d'énergie
massive d'énergie bas carbone qu'elle
soit renouvelable ou nucléaire d'autre
part nous suivons en cela les
recommandations du GIEC bio conseil pour
le climat et nous nous appuyons je
m'appuie sur les travaux de simulation
de RTE que vous connaissez bien
j'insisterai particulièrement sur le
levier de la sobriété énergétique avec
l'objectif de réduire notre consommation
d'énergie de 10% d'ici deux ans c'est la
première marche d'une réduction de 40%
de notre consommation d'énergie
nécessaire selon les experts pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
ce plan sobriété c'est un plan
volontaire de long terme qui part du
terrain et qui a vocation à être
irréversible il mobilise au premier chef
les grandes entreprises les grandes
collectivités locales et évidemment
l'état car l'effort doit venir tout
d'abord de ceux qui ont le plus de
moyens et de ceux qui ont plus d'impact
nous avons lancé en juin dernier cette
démarche il fera l'objet d'une
présentation demain avec la première
ministre l'état aura évidemment un
devoir d'exemplarité chaque ministère
déclinera ainsi sa feuille de route de
réduction de consommation de carburant
de gaz et d'électricité chaque secteur
présentera des engagements concrets pour
réduire sa consommation les entreprises
mais aussi les associations les
fédérations s'engageront à mettre en
oeuvre des mesures opérationnelles les
collectivités locales seront elles ne
sont déjà partie prenante de ce plan
beaucoup ont d'ailleurs relevé le défi
du plan sobriété les bonnes pratiques
sont partagées pour faciliter le travail
de celles qui disposent de moins de
moyens techniques et financiers pour
avancer nous déploerons également un
appui financier sous forme notamment de
C2E pour faciliter la mise en oeuvre de
certaines mesures de sobriété s'agissant
du grand public nous avons des demandes
récurrentes pour connaître les mesures
les plus efficaces en matière d'économie
d'énergie nous lancerons donc une
campagne à destination des Français pour
mettre en valeur ces mesures les plus
efficaces et je veux ici remercier les
énergéticiens avec lesquelles nous avons
coordonné cette communication grand
public autour des gestes qui permettent
à ceux qui le peuvent et j'insiste sur
ce point de faire des économies
d'énergie car je tiens à faire une mise
au point au regard de ce que j'ai pu
entendre ici et là il n'est pas question
de demander au 12 millions de Français
en situation de précarité énergétique
comme à tous ceux qui sont en situation
de sobriété choisie de faire des efforts
supplémentaires c'est une question de
justice sociale nous souhaitons au
contraire les accompagner pour sortir de
cette précarité notamment toute la
politique que nous déployons en matière
de thermique dès cet été j'ai également
demandé aux énergéticiens de s'engager
en faveur des Français en proposant en
français des modes de facturation
d'énergie qui valorisent leur effort de
sobriété et leur permettre de faire des
économies en contrepartie de la
réduction de leur consommation des
économies qui vont évidemment plus loin
que ce qu'elle serait par le jeu
classique de la facturation ces
nouvelles offres sont désormais
disponibles et j'appelle chacun à son
saisir parallèlement nous continuerons à
agir pour l'efficacité énergétique il
s'agisse du verdissement des transports
de la rénovation thermique ou de la
décarbonation de l'industrie nous avons
mis un coup d'accélérateur important au
cours du quinquennat précédent j'y
reviendrai quand j'évoquerai le budget
passons aux autres leviers sortir des
énergies fossiles cela suppose aussi de
développer massivement des alternatives
en termes de production d'énergie bas
carbone en France c'est ce que nous
faisons tant en matière d'énergie
renouvelable que d'énergie nucléaire car
notre combat ce n'est pas celui du
nucléaire contre les renouvelables qui
sont de type deux sources d'énergie bas
carbone ce n'est pas non plus celui de
la biodiversité contre le crime ma tant
la biodiversité dépendante de la
situation climatique et inversement
notre combat c'est celui de remplacer
les énergies fossiles par des énergies
décarbonées sortons donc des oppositions
dogmatiques qui ont dangereusement
paralysé ce débat la production massive
d'énergie décarbonée est déterminante
pour notre souveraineté pour notre
indépendance énergétique notre levier
pour sortir de notre dépendance
mortifère aux énergies fossiles
importées nous devons donc être en
mesure de produire 60% d'électricité de
plus qu'aujourd'hui pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 et il nous
faudra développer la marche forcée de la
chaleur renouvelable vous m'avez suivi
on baisse la consommation d'énergie de
40%, est néanmoins on doit augmenter la
production d'électricité de 60% et faire
un effort massif sur les énergies
renouvelables dont vous dire que c'est
pas tout à fait simple le rapport RTE
indique que nous pouvons y parvenir en
nous appuyant sur un mix des carboné et
équilibrer reposant et sur l'énergie
nucléaire et sur le développement massif
d'énergie renouvelable c'est le choix
écologique le plus pertinent le choix
économique le plus opportun et le choix
financier le moins coûteux or nous
n'avons pas de temps à perdre je
lancerai dans les prochains jours les
travaux sur la prochaine programmation
de l'énergie conformément au calendrier
que les parlementaires de la précédente
mandature ont souhaité mais compte tenu
des enjeux nous n'avons pas le luxe
d'attendre car nous savons que nous
avons besoin et de renouvelables et de
nucléaire
et quand je parle de renouvelable je
veux dire toutes les filières
renouvelables qu'il s'agisse de la
géothermie du biogaz de l'hydraulique du
photovoltaïque thermique ça ne se limite
pas à l'éolien et au photovoltaïques
comme je l'entends aussi parfois ces
objectifs seront ajustés dans le cadre
de la loi de programmation énergique
climat en 2023 à l'issue d'une
concertation que nous ouvrirons courant
octobre donc dans les tous prochains
jours
c'est dans ce contexte que j'ai fait le
choix dès maintenant de lancer un grand
plan sur les énergies renouvelables vous
le savez parce que c'est sans regret
on fixera combien d'énergie
renouvelables mais on sait déjà qu'on a
besoin d'accélérer les procédures
puisque nous mettons deux fois plus de
temps en moyenne que de nos voisins
européens pour faire du renouvelable
pour de multiples raisons et nous les
attaquons une à une sur le plan
réglementaire d'abord j'ai pris une
série de décrets dès cet été sur le plan
organisationnel en Suisse avec une
circulaire à destination des préfets et
en renforçant dès 2023 ça sera un des
éléments du projet de loi de finances
des effectifs qui instruisent les
procédures d'autorisation ces mesures
ont déjà permis de débloquer 10
gigawatts d'énergie solaire Etienne et
interawatts de gaz renouvelables le
projet de loi sur l'accélération du
développement des énergies renouvelables
dont la première monture vous a été
transmise cet été et qui a été présenté
dans une version un petit peu différente
en conseil des ministres et le volet
législatif de ce plan
il vise à lever les verrous
administratifs et de procédures sans
rien renier de nos exigences
environnementales nous agirons donc sur
quatre leviers le premier levier c'est
l'accélération des procédures par
exemple en prévoyant dès qu'un projet se
décide un raccordement au réseau sans
attendre que le projet soit terminé pour
entamer les démarches cela permet de
faire gagner une à plusieurs années de
procédure
libérez le foncier ensuite en mobilisant
en priorité les terrains déjà
artificialisés ou dégradés ou sans
difficulté patrimoniales ou
environnementales les parkings les
friches les bordures d'autoroute
ces mesures vont permettre de libérer
des espaces qui sont aujourd'hui
interdits inaccessibles ou qui ne sont
pas mobilisés suffisamment et donc de
doubler notre puissance solaire actuelle
je veux préciser ici que contrairement à
ce que j'ai pu lire le fait d'autoriser
ces terrains ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
fasse fait pas d'évaluation
environnementale bien sûr on les fera
mais on ne s'interdit pas d'implanter
des énergies renouvelables sur ces
terrains c'est ça qui est en jeu dans
cette loi et donc il y aura des mesures
de préservation pour les projets de
biodiversité mieux concerter ensuite en
permettant en particulier pour les
projets d'éoliennes marines un débat
mutualisé sur chaque façade maritime
pour décider avec les territoires et
leur temps du partage de l'espace
maritime sur chaque projet l'enjeu c'est
d'anticiper et de mener la concertation
en amont des porteurs de projets c'est
une demande qui vient des territoires
mieux partager la valeur enfin en
permettant au territoire de bénéficier
de la valeur créée par les projets de
renouvelables qu'ils accueillent
concrètement les habitants
et leur de leur et leur commune
profiteront directement des
installations avec une réduction de
leurs factures d'électricité cela me
permet d'ailleurs de rappeler que les
énergies renouvelables sont compétitives
et c'est ça qui permet d'apporter plus
de 20 milliards d'euros à notre budget
au titre de 2023 et qui permet de
financer une partie du bouclier
énergétique ce programme j'entends le
mener en prenant en compte deux
impératifs essentiels la préservation de
la biodiversité et l'association des
territoires
accélérer ne veut donc pas dire abaisser
les standards de protection de notre
environnement ni faire fi des
territoires nous voulons poser les
fondations d'impact territorial
énergétique
et pour cela je compte sur vous car j'en
entends beaucoup sur ces bancs parler de
souveraineté énergétiques et économique
j'en entends encore d'autres parler de
la nécessité d'agir face au
réchauffement climatique et de
développer les énergies renouvelables
c'est l'occasion pour chacun de prendre
ses responsabilités et je veux vous
remercier pour la mission
transparestisane que vous avez lancée
qui permet d'aller un cran plus loin et
de très concrètement faire des
propositions pour accélérer le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
par ailleurs nous devons relancer notre
filière nucléaire le président de la
République a annoncé son souhait de
lancer un programme de 6 EPR 1 milliard
d'euros du plan France 2030 sont par
ailleurs consacrés à cette filière pour
améliorer la recherche et développement
et l'innovation et nous souhaitons que
tous les réacteurs qui peuvent être
prolongés en sécurité le Soi ces enjeux
je les dis seront traités dans la
prochaine programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie sur laquelle le débat public
démarre dans les prochains jours et afin
de ne pas perdre de temps en parallèle
au projet de loi d'accélération des
procédures sur les énergies
renouvelables je porterai bientôt un
projet de loi équivalent qui sont sur
les procédures qui ne sont pas sur
combien de réacteurs puisque ça c'est
l'objet de la programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie mais vous l'avez compris
nous agissons en parallèle nous ne
sommes pas séquentiels je crois que
l'urgence énergétique l'exige pour la
mise en oeuvre de cette politique
énergétique mon ministère dispose d'un
budget d'un montant historique 19
milliards d'euros en 2023 pour financer
trois priorités continuer d'accompagner
concrètement les Français dans la
rénovation de leur logement et dans
l'achat de véhicules propres accélérer
la décarbonation de nos activités
protéger nos concitoyens face à
l'envolée des coûts de l'énergie nous
mobiliserons 2,5 milliards d'euros pour
financer le dispositif ma prime rénov
c'est 40% de plus que la trajectoire
2017-2019
le budget de mon ministère financera
auteur de 1,3 milliards d'euros le bonus
écologique et la prime à la conversion
et nous allons également pour les
professionnels continuer l'appel à
projet en faveur de l'électrification
des poids lourds mise en place avec le
plan de relance enfin la décarbonation
sera poursuivie grâce au Fonds Chaleur
géré par l'ADEME maintenu à 520 millions
d'euros en 2023 et au fond de
décarbonations de l'industrie qui
mobilisent comme vous le savez plus de 5
milliards d'euros dans le cadre de
France 2030 enfin dernière priorité dans
un contexte de crise énergétique mais
vous connaissez le sujet par cœur nous
consacrerons 12 milliards d'euros à la
prolongation du bouclier tarifaire sur
le gaz et l'électricité mon ministère
financera également le chèque énergie
exceptionnel qui bénéficiera à 40% des
ménages français c'était la volonté
d'avoir des missions des mesures plus
ciblées que vous nous avez exprimé je me
tiens maintenant à votre disposition
pour les questions
merci beaucoup madame la ministre nous
avons donc aux orateurs des groupes pour
le groupe Renaissance la parole est à
Antoine Armand
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues notre continent
est avec lui notre pays se trouve
confronté à une crise énergétique d'une
très grande gravité et dont les causes
s'avère multiples géopolitiques et
économiques au premier plan cette crise
nous place plus que jamais devant le
défi de la transition énergétique auquel
est désormais consacrée un ministère de
plein exercice dont vous avez la charge
ce qui ne peut que nous réjouir au vu de
vos précédents résultats en matière
industrielle cette transition
énergétique notre pays l'a entamé avec
volontarisme nous devons désormais
l'accélérer tant il y a urgence
urgence économique nationale car le bon
fonctionnement du pays et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises à terme
ne pourront pas être assurés sans la
garantie d'une sécurité
d'approvisionnement en énergie celle-ci
passera par le renforcement de nos
capacités de production autant par
l'accélération de nouvelles
implantations d'énergie renouvelables
que par le renforcement de notre parc
nucléaire qui feront l'objet tous deux
de textes que nous examinerons
prochainement
urgence écologique évidemment
l'évolution de notre mix énergétique
pour réussir la baisse de notre
consommation d'une part la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
serre et enfin l'amélioration de la
qualité de l'air demeure notre cap parmi
les gisements je voudrais ainsi ici sur
les sobriété et l'efficacité énergétique
par la rénovation de nos bâtiments
publics des particuliers et des
entreprises c'est le soutien continu et
inédit de nos gouvernements qui a permis
d'atteindre 700 000 rénovations
énergétiques par an et si l'on ne peut
que se féliciter de cette prise de
conscience collective et de
l'intensification de ce soutien il y a
500 millions d'euros supplémentaires
notamment dédiés à ma prime rénov dans
les projets de loi de Finances ainsi que
le soutien aux rénovations des bâtiments
publics grâce au fond vert il nous faut
désormais aller vers des rénovations
plus performantes et réduire la part de
monogestes coûteux pour nos finances
publiques et pas toujours efficace d'un
point de vue énergétique
urgence sociale enfin bien entendu sans
les boucliers massifs mis en place sans
délais par le gouvernement vous l'avez
dit le prix de l'énergie aurait pu
doubler sur la facture de nos
compatriotes et plus encore nous devons
continuer à accompagner les plus
précaires tout en sortant
progressivement et aussi vite que
possible des mesures d'urgence ainsi la
transition énergétique ne sera complète
que si ces trois volets sont pleinement
prises en compte le groupe Renaissance
soutiendra toutes les propositions en ce
sens au travers du projet de loi
financier ainsi que dans la construction
de notre avenir énergétique à travers le
projet de loi pour le développement
d'énergie renouvelable rassemblement
national la parole est à Emmanuel bléri
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre pour réussir à la transition
énergétique qu'il existe trois types de
solutions celles dont on sait qu'elle
marche celle dont on sait déjà qu'elle
ne marche pas et celle sur lesquelles il
raisonnable de s'engager celle qui
marche d'abord pour un objectif très
simple sur une production massive
d'énergie à bas prix et donc un avantage
compétitif considérable pour l'économie
française le tout en s'appuyant sur des
championnats industriels assurant notre
souveraineté énergétique sans recours
aux hydrocarbures le nucléaire français
vous l'aviez reconnu c'est le patrimoine
de la Nation toute entière abîmé lors
des derniers quinquennat dont vous êtes
aussi comptable et dans lequel il faut
investir massivement ensuite celle qui
ne marchent pas l'impasse énergétique
résultant de la préférence irrationnelle
pour de l'énergie interminante
intermittente pardon provoque
aujourd'hui la précarité énergétique de
millions de familles et creuse une
nouvelle fracture sociale pour ceux qui
doivent d'ores et déjà choisir entre se
déplacer ou se chauffer
il faut prononcer un moratoire sur
l'éolien et en suspente toutes les
subventions libre alors aux croyants de
cette religion de se faire aussi
pratiquant et d'en acheter l'énergie au
prix du marché laissez-moi vous faire
une confidence il tient pas l'hiver même
en col roulé enfin les solutions dont il
faut développer le potentiel la
géothermie et l'hydroélectricité dont il
parlait il paraît pardon étonnant que
certains veuillent encore privatiser
l'infrastructure pour garantir la
liberté de la mobilité individuelle
l'hydrogène apparaît à terme comme
l'unique source d'énergie massivement
stockable accessible nos polluantes en
tout cas bien moins que les batteries
actuelles pour conclure le point clé de
la transition énergétique réussie c'est
de la faire avec les Français et non
contre eux voilà pourquoi il faut
baisser la TVA sur les énergies de 20
points à 5,5 on ne s'inquiète pas de la
fin du monde prévue par les sapeurs
lorsqu'on a peur de la fin du mois merci
merci chers collègues pour la France
insoumise UPS la parole est à Loïc
Prudhomme
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre nous connaissons actuellement
l'une des plus graves crises
inflationniste de notre histoire crise
alimentée principalement par
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie et
notamment le prix de l'électricité qui a
atteint près de 1100 euros le
mégawattheure à la fin du mois d'août 10
fois son prix habituel face à cette
situation la Commission européenne a
fini par admettre qu'il était temps de
réformer les mécanismes du marché
européen d'électricité au passage je lui
fais confiance pour produire un système
tout aussi incompréhensible et inopérant
que le précédent empire le gouvernement
français en attendant brandi avec force
de publicité comme seule mesure le
bouclier tarifaire un bouclier tarifaire
il faut le dire clairement aussi financé
par le budget de l'État donc par nos
impôts mais ces mesures n'agissent que
dire que sur les symptômes de la crise
profonde que nous vivons c'est la
logique même de marché qu'il faut
remettre en cause sans le marché il n'y
aurait pas eu cette crise sur la facture
électrique les prix auraient suivi les
coûts du système électrique qui
augmenter que de 4% en 2021 par rapport
à 2020 sans le marché od EDF ne vendrait
pas son électricité à 50 euros le
mégawattheure à décor à des concurrents
virtuels qui la revendent à 500 euros le
mégawattheure sans avoir produit le
moindre électron alors qu'il s'y était
engagé il faut donc sortir de ces
mécanismes européens absurdes de fausses
concurrence et revenir à un tarif
réglementé basé sur les cours réels de
production pour garantir un prix stable
et prévisible il faut sortir de cette
mécanique financière de spéculation pure
et ne me dites pas que je souhaite
isoler la France de la solidarité
européenne la déconnecter du réseau les
interconnexions sont indispensables et
elles existaient bien avant que vous
n'appliquez votre délire financier à ce
secteur de l'énergie
vous nourrissez des requins de la
finance avec la chair des Français leur
salaire et vous venez leur expliquer la
bouche en cœur qui va falloir couper la
wifi et éviter les mails rigolos madame
la ministre l'effet sont têtus
allez-vous enfin reconnaître l'évidence
faillite de votre dogme du marché et
labandonnée avez-vous seulement
sollicité vos services pour étudier
cette voix alternative je vous remercie
pour les républicains la parole était
Emmanuel Maquet merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre la crise
énergétique est particulièrement
révélatrice pour le gouvernement il
n'aura fallu que deux entres la
fermeture de felsenheim et la guerre en
Ukraine pour voir s'opérer un virage à
180° sur le nucléaire vous déposez
maintenant deux projets de loi visant
accélérer les énergies renouvelables et
le nucléaire en accordant une large part
à ce que vous appelez l'acceptabilité je
souhaite m'arrêter un moment sur cette
notion d'acceptabilité au risque de
surprendre la clé de l'acceptabilité ce
n'est pas de mon point de vue la
concertation ce n'est pas l'organisation
de débat public décidé à l'avance et qui
ne font que paralyser l'action publique
ce n'est pas non plus le partage de la
valeur que vous proposez comme pour
faciliter voir pour acheter le
consentement des élus et des riverains
la clé de l'acceptabilité c'est de toute
évidence le succès le succès industriel
le succès commercial le succès
technologique et surtout le succès
énergétique qui ont été au rendez-vous
avec le nucléaire et qui a permis
l'accès à une énergie garantie souverain
et bon marché pour tous
rétrospectivement il n'y a pas eu trop
de débats au Parlement et de débat
public en général lors de la
construction du parc électro-nucléaire
pourtant le nucléaire bénéficie d'un
fort consensus réaffirmé dans les
sondages c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il est couronné de succès la
programmation plus réunionnelle de
l'énergie prévoit toujours la baisse de
la part du nucléaire à 50% du mix
énergétique en 2035 ma première question
est donc la suivante allez vous revenir
sur cette disposition législative et
accepter de relever ce seuil la deuxième
question concerne le temps long ou en
sont les énergies renouvelables
alternatives pouvez-vous nous évoquer
votre vision de l'actualité la
technologie autre que le solaire éolien
qui pourrait demain s'ajouter à notre
éventail du renouvelable quelle est
votre avis sur le soutien à la
méthanisation qui n'a pas son propre
titre dans le projet de loi est-ce que
l'hydraulique est à son plein
développement potentiel aujourd'hui
est-ce que l'énergie Marie motrice qui a
l'avantage d'être parfaitement
prédictible n'est pas une perspective
intéressante à l'heure où l'on cherche à
profiter de l'énergie marine mais aussi
la géothermie est plus particulièrement
la géothermie marine qui exploite les
calories thermiques d'une ressource
inépuisable la mer est-elle suffisamment
accompagnée dans son développement
monsieur le Président je termine dans un
contexte où la fermeture de Fessenheim
et l'abandon d'Astrid pèse lourd sur
votre bilan je souhaite enfin que nous
puissiez nous dresser un point sur la
situation de lithère de Cadarache la
perspective de la fusion nucléaire qui
génère une énergie infinie véritable
réponse à nos défis pour une croissance
propre pour et pérenne merci président
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant la parole est admis
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vous remercie au nom du
groupe démocrate moderne et apparentés
pour votre présence aujourd'hui devant
notre commission pour nous présenter
votre feuille de route et les enjeux
énergétiques du projet de loi de
finances je souhaite vous questionner
sur un sujet qui comme vous le savez me
tient à cœur celui de l'éolien en mer le
président de la République a fixé un
objectif de 40 Go d'électricité produit
par l'éolien en mer en 2050 soit 50
parcs une planification est attendue
pour nous permettre d'atteindre cet
objectif pour en garantir l'efficacité
l'acceptabilité les industriels de
l'éolien sont unanimes c'est un chantier
qui mérite un document propre et des
équipes suffisamment nombreuses et
agiles pour être menée à bien rapidement
et sous votre ministère et celui de la
mer un capitaine dédié je ne suis pas
certain de l'intérêt de réaliser ce
travail dans le cadre de la révision des
documents stratégiques de façade la
planification et la concertation sont
les éléments clés de l'acceptabilité
je peux pas conclure mon propos sans
évoquer le projet d'éolien flottant au
large de Belle-Île et de Groix une
technologie qui permet d'éloigner les
éoliennes à plus de 100 km de la côte
comme c'est le cas dans plusieurs pays
européens dont la Hollande la Hollande
qui a déjà défini toute sa planification
jusqu'à 2050 elle ne seront finalement
qu'à 20 km de Belleville malgré des
positions convergentes exprimées lors du
débat public par les élus locaux les
associations les industriels les
habitants nous avions tous souhaité que
le parc se fasse au delà des 12000
nautiques comment donc Madame la
Ministre comptez vous garantir la bonne
prise en compte des débats publics à
venir je vous remercie
merci cher collègue pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté la parole est à
chantage Jourdan
quel président madame la ministre merci
pour votre présence et votre
présentation nous notons que l'idée du
nécessaire sobriété notamment
énergétique a pris une place plus
importante dans le débat public
dernièrement et à notamment fait son
apparition dans le discours du
gouvernement ceci est principalement et
malheureusement dû aux événements
externes difficiles que nous connaissons
mais une bonne chose émerge les
questions de sobriété sont mises au
premier plan la question qui se pose
maintenant est de quelle sobriété
parlons-nous il est évident que le
circonstances impose à l'approche de
l'hiver que nous réalisions tous et
toutes des efforts individuels et
collectifs à court terme pour prévenir
le risque de pénurie d'électricité ou de
gaz c'est l'objet du plan sur lequel
vous avez travaillé et qui doit être
présenté demain néanmoins chez les
socialistes nous pensons que cet élan
autour de la sobriété doit aller plus
loin et permettre une réflexion sur le
moyen et long terme dans le contexte
actuel il est plus urgent de nous
interroger effectivement sur notre mode
de vie et sur notre modèle de
développement en prenant en compte son
impact sur le climat et les ressources
naturelles nous avons donc souhaité nous
inscrire en complément du travail
effectué sur la sobriété énergétique et
nous avons présenté ce matin une série
de mesures concrètes de cours et moyen
terme pour une sobriété solidaire guidée
par la justice sociale et le partage des
droits sociaux et environnementaux il
s'agit par exemple de massifier des
rénovations performantes et globales des
logements avec la mise en place d'un
zéro reste à charge pour les ménages de
favoriser l'accès aux transports
collectif du quotidien détendre au jet
privé la limitation des vols commerciaux
un tour d'huile dans la loi climat
résilience de mettre progressivement fin
aux écrans vidéo publicitaires de créer
une tarification sociale pour les
besoins essentiels pour financer cela
nous proposons un impôt sur la fortune
climat et biodiversité et une taxes sur
les super profits madame la ministre
pouvez-vous m'indiquer comment cette
réflexion indispensable de plus long
terme sur d'autres modèles de
développement notre façon de produire et
de consommer s'inscrit dans votre pour
le concours et à parenté la parole est à
Henri Alfandari
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues le contexte
international et l'accélération des
conséquences du changement climatique
nous oblige les ambitions du président
de la République et le volontariste de
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne nous place sur une
trajectoire ambitieuse de décarbonation
de notre mix énergétique pour ne tenir
une neutralité carbone en 2050 nous
devons réussir une réduction nette des
gaz à effet de serre de 55% par rapport
à 1990 dès 2030 2030 ces deux mains nous
devons accélérer le budget du ministère
de la transition énergétique annoncée
s'élève à hauteur de 19 milliards
d'euros pour 2023 associés au budget du
ministère de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires c'est
près de 60 milliards d'euros en faveur
de la décarbonation et de la transition
de notre société
un budget donc inédit qui démonte bien
l'ambition du gouvernement de tout faire
pour atteindre aux objectifs de
neutralité carbone les priorités du
ministère de la transition énergétique
sont également à saluer maintient accrue
des efforts pour accompagner les
Français et les collectivités dans la
rénovation énergétique des logements et
des bâtiments accompagnement vers les
mobilités durables notamment l'achat de
véhicule propre accélération du
développement et l'installation
d'énergie propre pour un mix des
carbonée et surtout une attention
continue à la protection des Français
face à l'os des prix de l'électricité et
du gaz
je tiens par ailleurs à saluer les
négociations de madame la ministre
auprès de l'Union européenne en ce qui
concerne la régulation du marché
européen de l'énergie ainsi madame la
ministre j'aurais pu vous demander
comment envisagez-vous cette équilibre
entre objectif national et déploiement
local comment pensez-vous conseiller le
temps nécessaire à l'appropriation
utile à la construction des projets et à
leur acceptabilité par la population
et l'obligation qui la note d'installer
au plus vite les capacités de production
qui nous permettront tenir nos objectifs
mais ma question portera sur une menace
immédiate le marché de l'énergie
pouvez-vous nous donner de la visibilité
sur les négociations en cours avec nos
partenaires européens il y a un risque
d'une rupture des approvisionnements des
chaînes de production ainsi pensez-vous
qu'une action coordonnée sur le
plafonnement du coût de l'énergie pour
l'ensemble des entreprises européennes
soit apportée de main merci chers
collègues pour le groupe écologiste
nupes la parole est à Nicolas Thierry
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre depuis plus d'un an nous
traversons une crise énergétique vous
l'avez dit dans l'ampleur est comparable
si ce n'est supérieur à celui du premier
choc pétrolier en 73 la crise s'annonce
par ailleurs durable mais cette crise
aurait pu être anticipée elle aurait dû
être anticipée de levier aurait en effet
permis de l'éviter le développement
massif des énergies renouvelables et la
promotion de l'efficacité énergétique en
la France est aujourd'hui le seul pays
de l'Union européenne être en dessous de
son objectif légal en matière d'énergie
renouvelable concernant l'efficacité
énergétique le Grenelle en 2007 nous
fixé l'objectif de 38% de réduction de
mes consommations dans le bâtiment d'ici
2020 d'après l'Observatoire national de
rénovation énergétique seul 1% de
l'objectif a été atteint à défaut
d'action nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
l'urgence et on tente de limiter la
casse avec un bouclier tarifaire mais le
bouclier tarifaire que vous proposez
présente plusieurs écueils il n'insiste
pas à réduire la consommation d'énergie
il subventionne autant les besoins
vitaux des plus modestes que l'énergie
superflu dépensée par les plus aisés en
clair les foyers qui peinent à chauffer
leur logement reçoivent un
accompagnement financier inférieur à
ceux qui par exemple chauffent leur
piscine en hiver il donc absolument
nécessaire de distinguer ce qui relève
de l'énergie dite vitale pour notamment
se chauffer se laver et manger de ce qui
relève de l'énergie dite superflue c'est
pourquoi le groupe écologiste propose
d'instaurer un accès universel à
l'énergie son principe est simple en
dessous d'un certain seuil correspondant
à la consommation moyenne des Français
les plus modestes tous les ménages
bénéficieraient d'un prix fortement
administré et plus bas que le tarif du
bouclier actuel on protège ainsi ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin et au-delà de
ce seuil toute consommation serait
tarifée auprès du marché donc forcément
des incitatifs ma question est simple le
gouvernement est-il prêt à faire évoluer
l'actuel bouclier et tarifaire pour
aller dans le sens de plus de justice
écologique et sociale merci
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
démocrate et républicain la parole est à
Jean-Victor castor
bonjour madame la ministre et chers
collègues monsieur le président
en fait j'avais déjà dit ici dans cette
commission que chaque fois je suis un
petit peu étonné des débats au moment où
je vous parle il y a une commune en
Guyane qui a 12000 habitants et qui n'a
pas d'électricité
et c'est le cas nous avons huit communes
sur 22 qui sont totalement isolés la
Guyane n'est pas en interconnexion avec
les pays environnantes donc la sobriété
énergétique on la connaît on l'a vu
depuis des dizaines d'années et les
efforts qui vont être demandés aux
Français et bien ce sont des efforts qui
n'ont pas de sens chez nous puisque
beaucoup de villages beaucoup de
contrées il n'y a pas de courant il n'y
a pas d'eau
alors moi ma question c'est quelle est
la feuille de route puisque la situation
de la gueule même si elle est très
particulière et singulière on ne peut
pas traiter les questions énergétiques
de la même façon
en France et dans nos territoires dit
d'outre-mer c'est un vrai problème et
les feuilles de route elles doivent être
décidées bien sûr avec les élus locaux
dans le cadre des plans uraniels de
l'énergie mais c'est notions qui sont
des notions qui sont conjoncturelles
même si elles l'Europe elles auraient dû
être structurelles plutôt pour vous nous
sommes à l'époque de l'électrification
tout simplement tant au niveau de la
production que du transport et de la
distribution
c'est un drame et nous devons raisonner
en termes d'urgence parce que vous savez
qu'il y a un climat d'insécurité avec
pratiquement une personne tuée
assassinée par semaine en Guyane donc
imaginez-vous moi dans ma commune la
commune de Matoury j'ai passé près de 10
heures sans électricité dans un quartier
où il fait une noire totalement en
pleine période d'insécurité où il y a
des braquages régulièrement
vraiment je j'insiste je suis presque en
colère au nom donc de tout de toute la
population guyanaise de devoir que
finalement on ne traite pas les
questions les questions fondamentales du
développement et de mise à disposition
de l'énergie voilà ce que je voulais
dire et j'espère que on aura vraiment un
régime singulier particulier pour nos
territoires et particulièrement pour la
Guyane pour l'urgence et pour le futur
merci cher collègue et enfin pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire la parole est à Benjamin
Sainte-Foy merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre tout le monde
s'accorde sur la nécessité d'agir au
regard de la crise énergétique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui si je suis le
squelette de votre intervention et que
je commence par parler des la place de
la réduction des énergies je vais vous
parler d'industrie nous recevions ce
matin France industrie vous avez évoqué
les 5 milliards d'investissements d'ici
2030 qui permettront on l'espère
d'atteindre les objectifs néanmoins
personne ne peut considérer que ce qui
se passe actuellement forcément ne
présente pas le risque de freiner la
capacité des entreprises industrielles à
accélérer le processus et ce matin je
dois dire que on a plutôt considéré que
le discours consistait à nous laisser
entendre que ce serait sans doute
difficile d'aller plus loin que ce qui
est demandé aujourd'hui au champ
industriels il ne faut pas le perdre de
vue si je continue sur le développement
des énergies bas carbone une remarque
sur les EnR la question de la place des
élus je pense que vous n'ignorez pas que
les élus du bloc communal interco ou
communaux s'interroge beaucoup sur leur
capacité à être intégrées et à
participer à l'élément de discussion on
a eu l'expression à l'instant du
collègue d'outre-mer et je pense que de
manière générale ça pose la question de
la planification territoriale et la
capacité à emmener les territoires dans
cette dans cette volonté de développer
le nr et puis un mot sur le nucléaire
pour terminer DF a pris engagement de
permettre la réactivation des 32
réacteurs d'ici
cet hiver où on décentrales nucléaires
ou en soit nous aujourd'hui les
opérations de maintenance et puis pour
reprendre vos propos vous avez dit tout
à l'heure tous les réacteurs qui peuvent
être prolongés dans des conditions de
sécurité doivent l'être est-ce que vous
avez une idée du nombre que ça
sous-entend et à quel dans quel échéance
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues l'ensemble des
orateurs de groupe ont pu s'exprimer
mesdames Lamy je vais vous laisser la
parole en sachant que nous allons d'ores
et déjà une vingtaine de questions et
que l'objectif est de finir autour de
18h30
madame la ministre
et que je suis souvent prolixe dans les
réponses donc je vous prie de m'excuser
d'avance monsieur Armand merci pour
je dirais
le panorama que vous vous baignez
effectivement je sais votre rôle dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finance 2023
donc on va avoir je pense à un certain
nombre d'enjeux ils ont d'ailleurs été
touché du doigt par certains notamment
sur la rénovation thermique en tout cas
moi je veux dire ma disponibilité pour
travailler sur ces sujets là on a des
marges de progrès je crois qu'il faut
savoir balayer devant notre porte mais
on a aussi fait beaucoup pour massifier
et accélérer la rénovation thermique
donc il faut continuer sur sur cette
lancée monsieur bléri vous mentionnez la
préférence irrationnelle pour les
énergies renouvelables je vais me
permettre de vous renvoyer à l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie au rapport
du GIEC au conseil pour le climat et à
toute une série d'experts qui
représentent à peu près 95% de la
science et de l'expertise en matière
énergétique et qui font du développement
massif des énergies renouvelables une
priorité à la fois en matière de
souveraineté énergétique mais également
en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique je me
permettrai pas de me
substituer à ces auteurs mais je crois
que leur lecture est très intéressante
et je vous y renvoie s'agissant du
moratoire sur les éoliennes et la
suspension des subventions je redise que
j'ai dit lors de mon propos introductif
c'est-à-dire que les énergies
renouvelables et notamment les éoliennes
permettent de financer aujourd'hui à
hauteur de 20 milliards d'euros notre
budget c'est ce que j'appelle une
subvention inversée c'est une
contribution à notre à notre pardon
projet à notre loi de finances
s'agissant de la géothermie et
l'hydraulique d'autres l'ont mentionnés
j'y reviendrai sont effectivement des
énergies qui sont très prometteuses et
sur lequel nous avançons
s'agissant la géothermie pour
anticiper elle ne nécessite pas en tout
cas nous n'avons pas de demande
particulière de la filière géothermie en
matière législative elle est elles sont
accompagnées dans le cadre de France
2030 en revanche s'agit sans de
l'hydroélectricité vous savez que nous
avons prolongé la convention la
concession de CNR donc ce sujet est
réglé nous avons un sujet autour de DF
et qui suppose de terminer l'opération
qui a été entamée de monter au capital
et en termes de
capacité ou de potentiels on a assez
largement mobilisé les capacités
existantes en France par contre on peut
sur chaque installation montée
probablement modulo quelques milliards
d'euros d'investissement de 20 ou 30% le
potentiel de ces installations en ayant
en tête que le réchauffement climatique
va aussi poser problème en termes de
potentiel il y a un potentiel de montée
en terme de technologie mais un risque
de moindre capacité puisque nous aurons
moins de ressources
d'eau sur l'hydrogène oui c'est une
ressource prémentale c'est d'ailleurs un
des axes qui est supporté de manière
très importante par ce gouvernement à
travers du plan de relance et de France
2030 c'est 9 milliards d'euros qui ont
été mis sur la table nous avons porté le
projet européen et j'espère que vous le
saluerez de filière hydrogène avec
plus d'une dizaine de projets d'usine
hydrogène qui ont été annoncés par la
première ministre je crois que c'était
la semaine dernière par contre ça ne
sera pas la technologie de la mobilité
individuelle là aussi je vous renvoie
vers le haut conseil de l'hydrogène il y
a des travaux très précis sur ces sujets
là c'est particulièrement adapté pour la
décarbonation de l'industrie
probablement pas mal adapté pour la
mobilité lourde mais la mobilité
individuelle aujourd'hui encore une fois
je ne m'élève pas au dessus de ma
condition je ne suis pas une experte
mais je m'inspire des travaux
scientifiques c'est plutôt l'électrique
qui aujourd'hui tient la corde
évidemment il ne faudra pas faire la
transition sans les Français c'est pour
ça que nous menons aussi ces travaux de
débat public avec la Commission
nationale du débat public monsieur
prud'hommes vous dites que les faits
sont têtus sur la réforme du marché et
je veux vous dire que les faits sont
têtus c'est-à-dire que ça fait plus de
14 mois que nous travaillons sur la
réforme du marché européen Bruno Le
Maire barbara Pompili moi-même c'est la
France qui est aujourd'hui à la manœuvre
et c'est la France qui a fait bouger
l'Union européenne sur ces sujets là
inversement il faut pas non plus
raconter tout est son contraire
c'est-à-dire que le marché européen
c'est celui qui nous permet 20 jours de
l'année l'année dernière d'avoir accès à
une électricité dont on a besoin et qui
est produite au coût marginal de la
centrale la plus chère c'est à dire que
c'est normal de couvrir les coûts de
production ça s'appelle ne pas vendre à
perte en fait je me permets de le
préciser monsieur Maquet
la question de l'acceptabilité
vous mentionnez le suc industriels
commerciales énergétique du nucléaire et
le fait que le nucléaire n'a jamais fait
l'objet de à toujours été consensuel
dans l'opinion publique c'est vrai c'est
pas complètement vrai je veux rappeler
que les épisodes de Tchernobyl et de
Fukushima ont légèrement rafraîchi
l'atmosphère il faut en être conscient
et donc il y a eu une période quand même
de creux sur l'opinion publique donc il
faut être extraordinairement attentif
sur la sécurité cela ne veut pas dire
que notre filière nucléaire n'est pas un
succès c'est un succès c'est ce qui nous
a permis d'abaisser de à peu près un
tiers notre dépendance énergétique donc
on doit continuer mais c'est pas parce
que le nucléaire a été un succès qu'on
doit le relancer que les énergies
renouvelables ne peuvent pas être à
succès je vais prendre l'exemple de
l'éolien marin aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
et il faut qu'on puisse continuer nous
avons les principaux briques
technologiques de construction de la
filière éolienne marraine c'est-à-dire
que nous sommes capables de faire les
nacelles nous sommes capables de faire
les pales nous sommes capables de faire
les moteurs et ça ça a une vraie valeur
dans des projets que nous portons vous
pourriez m'opposer le photovoltaïque et
vous auriez raison sur le photovoltaïque
d'un point de vue industriel près de 80%
de part de marché sont aujourd'hui
chinoises et c'est un vrai sujet et donc
oui dans la politique énergétique il y a
un sujet industriel que nous devons
porter porter dans les marchés publics
portez dans l'un négociation et les
cahiers des charges de nos énergies
renouvelables et porter aussi en termes
de développement industriel sur et 2 et
de règles du jeu européenne je pense que
les mécanismes inclusion carbone aux
frontières ou le règlement batterie
électrique sont des avancées assez
prometteuses sur ce sujet là vous avez
posé également beaucoup de questions la
baisse à 50% de notre pixel énergétique
du nucléaire c'est une augmentation
ayez-le en tête puisqu'à partir du
moment où nous augmentons notre
production d'électricité vous avez un
effet de balance qu'il faut pas de
sous-estimer donc c'est beaucoup plus
d'énergie renouvelables mais en montant
brut probablement plus d'énergie
nucléaire ce qui pas évident compte tenu
de l'effet d'arriver à leur fin de
d'exploitation d'un certain nombre de
centrales nucléaires ça va être un des
débats je pense très important de la PPE
les autres technologies donc là encore
vous avez mentionné la géothermie donc
je l'ai déjà fait la réponse
l'hydraulique le soutien la
méthanisation là aussi ce n'est pas dans
le projet loi parce que la filière nous
a pas remonté de besoin on vient d'en
repérer un très récemment qui est les
PPA dont vous avez dû voir cet article
qui peut-être élargie au gaz
renouvelable et effectivement tel qui
est écrit l'article ce n'est pas
possible donc voilà il y a quelques
pistes probablement mais elles sont pas
si multiples que ça sauf si vous nous en
remontez et nous on est très motivé pour
le faire je veux qu'il y ait pas de
débat sur ITER c'est vraiment un projet
long terme donc il continue à tenir à
peu près ces cadencements il y a des
dates 2025 2027 je vais pas redonner le
détail mais il est bien sur sa
trajectoire de de projet mais c'est pas
ça qui va résoudre le problème de
l'hiver prochain mais je pense que vous
le savez évidemment parfaitement
monsieur pas un éloigné les éoliennes
certainement mais je rappelle qu'il n'y
a pas de projet flottants industriels
aujourd'hui dans le monde il y en a pas
vous me citez les Pays-Bas les Pays-Bas
ont la chance d'avoir un plateau qui est
beaucoup moins profond que le nôtre vous
savez que nous on descend beaucoup plus
rapidement sur nos côtes c'est bien
notre problème et donc pour faire du
flottant il faut avoir la technologie
aujourd'hui technologie éprouvée c'est
du poser dans la Baltique il pose dans
la Baltique qui pose il pose sur des
profondeurs qui sont malheureusement
pour nous beaucoup plus proches de nos
côtes et on a effectivement deux projets
de flottants mais qui sont de capacités
on va dire démonstrative à ce stade et
avec des coûts de production qui sont
beaucoup plus élevés ça veut pas dire
qu'on va pas y arriver on va y arriver
mais probablement après 2030 d'où c'est
ces temps intermédiaire pour quelques
projets et encore une fois vous n'aurez
pas 50 projets de poser vous aurez 50
projets de poser et de flottant avec
effectivement une programmation et là où
je reviens c'est qu'il faut une
programmation écologique et regardez
comment on peut jouer sur les différents
les différents territoires mais on n'a
pas la chance ou la malchance je ne sais
pas il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients d'avoir comme certains
nombres de pays du Nord peu de
profondeur assez loin de nos côtes
sur
Madame Jourdan sur la sobriété peut-être
deux choses j'ai pris connaissance
effectivement
de la contribution que votre groupe a
fait sur une sobriété solidaire avec 10
grandes mesures d'abord je salue le fait
que vous en parliez de ce sujet je pense
que c'est évidemment très positif
ensuite lorsque je regarde les mesures
qui sont proposées c'est beaucoup de
mesures de taxation ou d'imposition de
fiscalité ou d'efficacité énergétique
donc on n'est pas complètement dans le
sujet de la sobriété et moi je vous
renvoie aux travaux notamment de
Negawatt ou de Réseau ACTION crime avec
lesquels nous avons travaillé sur le
plan sobriété nous nous travaillons à
changer les comportements ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des sujets que vous
touchez qui sont utiles de manière
générale dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'ils sont complètement sur le
sujet de la sobriété puis je vais vous
renvoyer sur fit for festify le paquet
climat européen parce que pour le coup
dans le paquet climat européen vous
retrouvez la question de la la taxation
en tout cas de la prise en compte d'un
certain nombre de secteurs avec des
mesures qui sont européennes donc
beaucoup plus puissantes et qui vise
effectivement à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
passagers clandestin qui ne paierait pas
entre guillemets leur contribution
en émission de carbone je parlais du
transport maritime je parlais de
l'aviation tous les secteurs sont
aujourd'hui couverts par ce paquet
climat de 3500 pages et qui est
extraordinairement ambitieux et que nous
allons probablement finaliser dans les
prochains mois avec un accord global qui
a été emporté par la présidence
française et notamment
je dirais avec la force de traction du
président de la République
Monsieur alphonerie conciliation du
court terme et du moyen terme dans les
énergies renouvelables moi je vous
l'avais compris je crois
à la
je crois effectivement à la
planification écologique nous avons
lancé des comités régionaux de l'énergie
c'est un début on sait que la région
c'est un niveau qui est peut-être un peu
trop haut encore et qu'il faut descendre
au niveau des départements néanmoins les
régions ont des
compétences de développement économique
et énergétique et ça c'est intéressant
donc ça c'est probablement le premier
point dans la circulaire adressée au
préfet nous les mobilisons non seulement
sur le fait de traiter individuellement
les dossiers et de faire en sorte qu'il
dit oui et des noms mais qui est pas
d'incertitude mais nous leur demandons
aussi de faire ce travail de
concertation avec les élus et notamment
d'aide et d'accompagnement en termes
d'aide à la décision et de cartographies
des territoires je pense que si déjà on
s'é cartographié les territoires en
disant qu'il y a des territoires qui
sont plus propices pour poser des
énergies renouvelables et quel type
d'énergie renouvelable et des
territoires qu'ils sont moins parce que
PPR parce que si tu remarquable d'un
point de vue patrimonial parce que tout
simplement pas d'acceptabilité c'est des
points sur lequel il faut être vigilant
maintenant il faut que lorsqu'on prend
une carte de département on n'est pas
juste un tout petit point de territoire
acceptables par rapport à une un besoin
de production qui serait beaucoup plus
important et c'est un peu ce que je veux
conduire dans la PPE c'est d'arriver à
voir aussi cette visualisation de
l'écart entre le possible et le
nécessaire ou le ou l'acceptable est
nécessaire
sur la question des négociations en
cours niveau européen oui une action
coordonnée et je pense possible en tout
cas on a beaucoup avancé ces derniers
jours vous savez que nous avons trois
sujets au fond le premier sujet c'est
celui qui tourne autour du prix du gaz
et de son potentiel plafonnement avec
deux sous-sugs le sujet de du
plafonnement du prix du gaz qui arrive
par gazoduc parce que ce sont des
fournisseurs qui ont un peu moins de nos
capacités à réorienter leurs flux et
donc qui serait dans une capacité à
négocier de manière plus profonde avec
nous que d'autres que d'autres
fournisseurs de gaz moi j'ai vu mon
homologue climatique norvégien hier à
Kinshasa puisque j'étais en préparation
de la COP 27 pendant deux jours qui
arrivent affirmé la volonté très forte
du Premier ministre de trouver des
solutions vous savez que d'autres pays
ont déjà des prix tout à fait
compétitif deuxième sujet c'est le GNL
là le général nous sommes sur un marché
mondial et je veux rappeler que pour
ceux qui me disent que la crise aurait
pu être anticipée je rappelle qu'en fait
c'est 40% du gaz européen qui a disparu
donc moi je veux bien que la crise
pouvait être anticipée mais ce qui avait
lu dans une
boule de cristal qui aurait une
intervention une agression russe contre
l'Ukraine et que ça allait arrêter les
livraisons de gaz et de carburant dans
les mois qui ont suivi cette agression
je vais les féliciter pour leur pression
en l'occurrence c'est un choc
énergétique majeur exogène et c'est une
guerre
et c'est une guerre contre nos valeurs
donc elle n'était pas forcément
anticipable en tout cas deuxième sujet
le GNL il faut remplacer sans terawatts
de gaz russe et le marché mondial c'est
400 terawatts de GNL donc vous imaginez
ce que ça signifie en terme de choc de
d'offres et en fait le GNL ça ne se
produit pas si facilement que ça donc il
faudra trois quatre ans pour arriver à
augmenter ou avoir des installations qui
prennent le relais donc on est bien dans
un situation de gestion
de de flux le Tagada et le dernier point
c'est effectivement la déconnexion du
prix du gaz et de prix l'électricité là
nous avançons sur un système en mode
mécanisme ibérique revisité pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe et la négociation
se poursuit de ma mes équipes ont une
discussion technique avec la direction
générale énergie et l'ensemble des pays
européens qui pour pour rentrer dans le
détail mais je trouve que ça avance
raisonnablement bien sur ce sujet là en
tout cas ce qui est clair c'est que les
ministres sont convaincus qu'il faut
avancer qu'il y aura un point sur ce
sujet là au Conseil informel européen de
fin de semaine
sur Monsieur Thierry donc la crise
aurait pu être anticipé je me suis
permis de vous répondre le développement
massif des eaux énervé vous avez raison
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous portons
aujourd'hui et je compte sur le soutien
de votre groupe sur le projet de loi que
nous présentons j'ai cru entendre que il
n'était pas complètement acquis mais je
suis à votre disposition pour y
travailler sur la rénovation thermique
la rénovation thermique je me permets de
m'inscrire en faux sur ce que vous
indiquez sur la stratégie nationale
baccarmon le secteur du bâtiment de ceux
qui a le plus contribué en fait et pas
d'un pourcent en réalité et d'ailleurs
c'est celui qui devrait le plus
contribuer dans les années qui viennent
et je rappelle que entre 2018 ce que
nous avons une stratégie nationale pas à
carbone qui démarre en 2018 nous sommes
en ligne avec notre budget carbone
c'est-à-dire que nous avons tenu notre
trajectoire nous avons tenu notre
trajectoire encore ça mérite d'être
indiqué et nous travaillons sur une
stratégie nationale bac carbone
complémentaire qui suppose d'accélérer
encore le rythme de réduction de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
puisque nous avons rehaussé au niveau
européen de près de 30 % de notre
objectif de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre à horizon 2030 nous sommes le
continent le plus ambitieux en matière
de réduction des gaz à effet de serre ça
aussi c'est un fait
s'agissant du bouclier tarifaire je vais
vous répondre avec le chèque énergie en
fait le chèque énergie c'est aujourd'hui
le dispositif qui est le plus ciblé qui
a le taux de recours le plus élevé et
c'est ce que nous disent les
organisations syndicales c'est ce que
nous disent les associations parce que
je les ai rencontrées les associations
de lutte contre la précarité c'est ce
que nous disent les ONG et en plus c'est
un dispositif qui favorise la sobriété
monsieur castorld vous avez complètement
raison de souligner la situation je ne
vous vois pas hop là voilà c'est parce
que Monsieur matin est grand
vous avez complètement raison de
souligner la situation en Guyane la
situation en Guyane n'est pas digne d'un
pays comme la France nous avons vous
savez ce qui s'est passé cet été aussi
où il y a eu des longues heures de
coupures d'électricité sur des secteurs
complets de la Guyane et nous avons été
enfin moi j'ai été mobilisée avec
l'UDF pour suivre le rétablissement des
infrastructures vous êtes une zone non
interconnectée comme il est convenu de
l'appeler il faut une PPE spécifique moi
je suis prête à y travailler vous savez
que Jean-François caraco également vous
savez que nous bataillons sur la
centrale du larrivo pour faire en sorte
là encore d'obtenir des résultats ce
n'est pas simple vous savez qu'il y a un
contentieux qui est en cours sur lequel
la position de l'État a été constante et
moi je veux dire de manière plus large
c'est valable pour les territoires
d'outre-mer mais c'est également valable
pour la Corse qui sont des
non-interconnectés il nous faut des PPE
il nous faut des engagements et il nous
faut une décarbonation c'est absolument
essentiel et je suis prête à y
travailler
monsieur s'intuile vous avez
parfaitement raison de mentionner le
sujet des entreprises industrielles dans
le moment présent je me réjouis qu'on
ait une chômage partiel ou l'activité
partielle même si ce n'est pas
satisfaisant pour maintenir à flot ses
industries qui étaient partis très
fortement dans la décarbonation et je
veux vous indiquer que je vais rebalayer
l'ensemble des projets de décarbonation
parce que autant nous avons tenu
en dépit de l'augmentation de
l'inflation et ses projets ont été
poursuivis autant j'entends aujourd'hui
des interrogations sur est-ce qu'on a
les moyens est-ce que on peut continuer
ces projets décarbonation or ils sont
nécessaires à notre pays puisque je
rappelle la grosse partie de notre
empreinte carbone c'est une empreinte
importée
ce qui est voilà c'est on perd sur les
deux côtés l'économie et l'écologie donc
il faut qu'on arrive à faire en sorte
bon produire en France produire dans des
conditions sociales et environnementales
exigeantes et effectivement décarbonée
nous industries sur les énergies
renouvelables vous avez mentionné la
place des élus je crois y avoir répondu
avec les comités régionaux de l'énergie
mais vous avez parfaitement raison sur
le nucléaire vous savez que il y a un
site qui c'est celui de RTE qui vous
donne jour à jour la situation des
centrales on est à combien aujourd'hui
[Musique]
avec EDF qui a joué le jeu et qui a
incorporé dans son programme
d'excellence opérationnelle ces
différentes mesures il doit les déployer
mais là encore ça prendra quelques
années il y a notamment un enjeu de
formation et d'attractivité des métiers
au passage on constate que
l'attractivité des métiers est en train
d'évoluer en tout cas dans les carrières
d'ingénieurs ce qui est une très bonne
nouvelle
c'est le succès que vous mentionnez
réacteur à prolonger quel pourcentage
une excellente question je ne suis pas à
la SN donc je pense que la SN pourrait
vous donner une meilleure réponse mais
ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que la
prolongation au-delà de 50 ans et a
priori acquise pour l'ensemble de nos
réacteurs la prolongation jusqu'à 60 ans
sera une véritable question qu'il faudra
prendre dans la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie des sensibilités par
rapport à ce sujet là parce que nous ne
pouvons pas garantir aujourd'hui que
tous les réacteurs sont en situation
d'être prolongés jusqu'à 60 ans donc oui
c'est une bonne question je crois savoir
que la SN a des idées sur le sujet mais
je pense qu'il vaut mieux que vous les
interrogez parce que c'est une autorité
indépendante
merci Madame la Ministre ce que je vous
propose c'est que nous puissions prendre
toutes les questions madame la ministre
répond comme elle le peut au regard du
temps qu'il lui reste et puis
je vous propose c'est que vous puissiez
faire sans doute des réponses s'il y a
encore
des points qui n'ont pas été abordés je
laisse la parole à Antony Bros
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre alors que le prix de l'énergie
s'envole bien que contenu par le
bouclier tarifaire mise en place par le
gouvernement l'une des pistes que nous
pouvons poursuivre et celles de
l'autoconsommation et notamment
l'autoconsommation collective celle-ci
vise à mutualiser les productions les
productions les usagers c'est ce qu'on
appelle le foisonnement ainsi en 2019 le
rayon pris en compte pour considérer
qu'il s'agit bien d'une action
collective a été étendue à 1 km de
distance et une puissance cumulée de 3
mégawatts soit jusqu'à 200 foyers malgré
cette première avancée un frein demeure
en autoconsommation collective les
usagers doivent payer des taxes dont la
TVA plus importantes que pour
l'autoconsommation individuelle qui en
est qui en est exonéré jusqu'à 3 kW de
production afin d'accélérer la
transition énergétique des foyers
français le foisonnement constitue-t-il
selon vous une réponse crédible le cas
échéant des incitations fiscales
sont-elles envisagées afin d'accélérer
le déploiement de l'autoccasion contre
l'autoconsommation collective merci la
parole est à Philippe Guillemard
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre en présentant le budget de
votre ministère dans le cadre du projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 vous l'avez
qualifié de particulièrement élevés en
effet le montant à louer au défi de la
transition énergétique culmine à 19
milliards d'euros ça a été rappelé tout
à l'heure dans ce PLF et en aide
progression par rapport à 2022 le
gouvernement affiche l'une de ses
priorités le logement est plus
précisément la rénovation énergétique
pour près de 2,5 milliards d'euros à
louer à ma prime rénov vous l'avez
souligné Madame le Ministre à cette fin
ce sont plus de 500 millions d'euros qui
sont alloués au bailleur sociaux
financés sur le budget de l'Agence
nationale pour l'habitat la traduit
clairement la volonté de porter un
effort croissant sur les rénovations
globales j'attire toutefois votre
attention sur les difficultés que
rencontre certains ménages à obtenir
l'aide m'a pris vraiment dans la
rénovation énergétique c'est des
dysfonctionnements ponctuels a priori de
la plateforme ou un décalage de
versements de cette prime cependant le
dispositif un franc succès puisque j'ai
noté 700 000 foyers quelle disposition
envisagez-vous pour perfectionner ce
dispositif merci cher collègue la parole
est à Lionel cosse merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais vous remonter
quelques témoignages que j'ai
d'entreprises et des lieux de mon
département des Landes tout d'abord au
concernant des entreprises qui ont leur
contrat de fournisseurs d'électricité de
gaz qui s'arrête au 312 2023 qui voit
leur propre fournisseurs alors qu'il y a
jamais eu d'impayés de la part de
l'entreprise refuser de leur faire une
offre pour pouvoir leur garantir ce
service à partir au début 2023
d'autant plus grave comme problème que
ces entreprises bénéficient des aides de
l'État dans le cadre du Plan France sur
Roland c'est lorsque certaines offres
arrivent il est demandé des dépôts de
garantie de plusieurs millions d'euros
ce qui rend l'offre inacceptable par
l'entreprise deuxième sujet j'ai aussi
des chefs d'entreprise qui
souhaiteraient déployer des panneaux
photoaltiques sur leur toiture et qui se
voient confrontés à des assurances qui
refusent de répondre donc beaucoup de
projets sont à l'arrêts je pense que
vous avez connaissance de ce sujet donc
est-il possible de renforcer un petit
peu la main aux assureurs ou d'avisangée
un système assurantiel de l'État merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Damien Adam merci monsieur le Président
Madame les ministres j'aimerais vous
interroger sur deux sujets le premier
c'est qui aujourd'hui il est possible
d'installer des solutions de stockage à
domicile notamment quand on a des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur son toit ou
dans sa résidence et j'aimerais vous
interroger sur l'opportunité qui
pourrait y avoir pour la France de
mettre en place un crédit d'impôt pour
inciter les propriétaires de panneaux
photovoltaïques à installer ces
solutions de stockage à domicile ce qui
permettrait de lisser les pointes de
consommation le deuxième sujet sur
lesquels j'aimerais vous entendre c'est
la présentation de votre feuille de
route sur le développement des
infrastructures de recharge pour les
véhicules électriques à batterie et
également sur le sujet de l'hydrogène si
vous pouvez nous en donner quelques
éléments sur votre feuille de route pour
les prochaines années je serai très
heureux merci beaucoup merci cher
collègue la parole est à Laurence mayeri
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre merci pour vos propos à vos
propos et explications sur les sujets
très importants moi ça c'est une
question plutôt technique liée à
l'application
du en tout cas des arrêtés pris en
application du décret sur la
compagnement ma prime rénove et
notamment deux articles qui semblent
sauf erreur de ma part en attente pour
que le dispositif mon accompagnateur
rénove soit pleinement opérationnel
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner un
calendrier merci madame la ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Daniel brebois merci monsieur le
Président Madame ministre tout d'abord
moi je veux saluer votre énergie votre
détermination aussi bien pour soutenir
les ménages que les entreprises et votre
vos interventions
très judicieux et favorable auprès des
énergéticiens on l'a vu quand il a fallu
augmenter de 21 tarif à Rennes
simplement nous avons beaucoup à faire
dans les énergies renouvelables ce sont
les petits ruisseaux qui font les
grandes rivières demain dans le Jura
nous allons dans une commune de sang
habitants inauguré la plus grande ferme
solaire de la région c'est-à-dire 29
500 mégawh et donc ce projet a mis 10
ans pour aboutir et donc on nous avons
vraiment des freins à lever et je pense
que c'est les projets Inès localement si
on n'a pas la vision locale les projets
en énergie renouvelables ne
n'aboutissent pas donc il nous faut
absolument lever ses freins et puis il y
a une autre source d'énergie dont nous
parlons très peu alors que nous
enfouissons encore des tonnes de
plastique ce sont les CSR les
combustibles solides de récupération la
filière n'avance pas alors que c'est
quand même bien dommage pour le moment
elle est réservée aussimenteries et je
pense que on pourrait la développer on
ne peut plus enfouir du plastique
aujourd'hui c'est merci chers collègues
la parole est à Stéphane bijoux
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre la semaine
dernière à l'occasion de votre
déplacement avec la première ministre
dans les hauts de France sur le sujet de
sur le sujet de l'hydrogène pardon
Elisabeth borne arrive affirmé
l'engagement de l'État en faveur de
cette filière avec un investissement à
hauteur de 9 milliards d'euros comme
vous le savez la Vendée est l'un des
départements modèles dans le domaine
avec notamment le premier fournisseur
d'hydrogène vert l'entreprise Life qui
inaugurait à Saint-Nazaire il y a
quelques une dizaine de jours ça
première plateforme
en mer aussi ma question est la suivante
pouvez-vous nous apporter davantage de
précisions quant au déploiement de cette
enveloppe notamment en faveur donc de
l'hydrogène vers merci beaucoup merci
chers collègues la parole est à David
Valence
madame la ministre le 23 au 23 juin
dernier vous étiez au côté de la
première ministre pour annoncer le
lancement d'un plan de sobriété
énergétique décliné en 9 secteurs un des
groupes de travail de ce plan de
sobriété énergétique s'est penché sur la
question des transports en lien avec
votre collègue Clément baume que nous
recevions ici hier vous deviez du reste
en annoncé certaines des conclusions
décisions et préconisations ce sera fait
prochainement aura un des leviers
majeurs pour une plus grande sobriété
des transports est à trouver du côté du
covoiturage malgré la création du format
mobilité durable cher à notre président
et des preuves de covoiturage malgré
l'engagement des collectivités
territoriales plus de 80% des véhicules
restent occupés par un seul conducteur
en moyenne en France plus encore pour
les trajets de missiles travail madame
la ministre ma question est donc simple
avec votre collègue Clément Beaune
comment comptez-vous convaincre les
Français de pratiquer plus le
covoiturage des cet hiver
et merci pour le clin d'oeil sur le
forfait mobilité durable la parole est à
Sandrine Lefeuvre
production Agri voltaïsme de nombreux
travaux parlementaires s'attelent à la
question de sa définition et de son
encadrement et pour ma part je prêche
pour une définition qui soit large et un
encadrement raisonné permettant
d'atteindre nos objectifs de production
énergétique tout en respectant les
écosystèmes et la biodiversité dans ma
question elle est simple madame la
ministre comment pensez-vous encadrer ce
mode de production dans les textes
législatifs à venir je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Annie cousin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre les dirigeants des trois
énergéticiens français Total énergie EDF
et engie appellent les Français à
réduire immédiatement leur consommation
de carburant pétrole électricité et gaz
face au risque de pénurie qui menacent
notre pays pour cet hiver et face à la
flambée des prix aux difficultés
d'approvisionnement en gaz liés aux
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
s'ajoutent des tensions sur les
capacités de production en Europe et une
production hydraulique amputée en raison
de la sécheresse et donc qui est impacte
notre production nucléaire ce matin on
apprenait kiné 10 pouvait couper les
ballons d'eau chaude des particuliers
via des compteurs Linky personne ne peut
accepter que dans quelques semaines les
Français renoncent à se chauffer ou à
avoir de l'eau chaude car la facture
deviendrait insurmontable pour eux et
que notre production ne permettrait pas
de subvenir à la demande
la France est en voie de tiers
mondialisation madame la ministre quelle
garantit avez-vous pour assurer aux
Français en hiver au chaud et sans
difficulté je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre tout d'abord merci d'être parmi
nous la feuille de route du gouvernement
consacre à la mobilité électrique des
investissements colossaux 300 millions
d'euros pour les bornes de recharge pour
les voitures électriques 250 millions
d'aides à l'achat d'un vélo électrique
et enfin l'électrification des
transports publics et commerciaux ma
question concerne la faisabilité de
votre engagement comment pouvez-vous
justifier que 2023 soit une année
d'accélération de l'électrification des
transports provoquant une très forte
augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie quand madame borne il y a tout
juste deux jours explique devant
l'assemblée que 2023 sera au contraire
l'année de la sobriété énergétique et
notamment électrique demandant à nos
entreprises et nos industries de faire
de grands efforts quitte à impacter la
production prévoyant une hausse toujours
plus importante des prix de l'énergie
imputant très lourdement le budget des
ménages prévoyant même des coupures
d'électricité ciblée dans les domicile
de nos concitoyens madame la ministre
dans ce contexte comment qui vous
disposez de quantités suffisantes en
électricité pour réaliser tous ces
projets à leur qu'aujourd'hui vous
justifiez les augmentations du prix du
mégawatt par la difficulté de production
et en pénurie d'électricité merci la
parole est à Nicolas dragon
monsieur le Président chers collègues
madame la ministre à partir du 15
octobre une partie des 4,3 millions de
clients particuliers français mais
également petit professionnel et des
collectivités locales et Léon souscrit
un abonnement heure pleine ou heures
creuses ne pourront plus chauffer leur
eau entre midi et 14h par
l'intermédiaire d'un ballon d'eau chaude
électrique cette restriction pour être
opérée par le compteur Linky dont nous
avait pourtant garanti le nom
d'intrusion dans la vie privée des
clients au-delà de l'annonce d'un recul
sans précédent de nos modes de vie par
des choix
énergétiques des mauvais choix
énergétiques pris par les pouvoirs
publics comment comptez-vous vraiment
rassurer les Français avec un tel décret
que vous avez pu signer et exclure
désormais des coupures d'électricité
franche les Français ont-ils vraiment de
l'eau chaude cet hiver je vous remercie
madame la ministre la parole est à
Nathalie dacore
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous souhaitez prolonger la vie
des réacteurs nucléaires alors pourquoi
avoir fermé Fessenheim qui n'avait que
40 ans en parfaite état selon des
spécialistes et dont la puissance était
équivalente à 3000 et éoliennes qui ne
tournent que quand il y a du vent merci
merci chers
madame la ministre si le bouclier est
arrivé très temporaire quoi que vous en
promettiez si la France n'arrive pas à
sortir de la liaison du prix de
l'électricité à celui du gaz je pense
aussi aux Français chauffés au fioul ou
au granules de bois comment allez-vous
les aider alors que le fioul est
désormais presque aussi cher que le
gasoil et que les pellets ont augmenté
de 300% en quelques semaines
sur l'hydrogène la première ministre a
effectivement annoncé des financements
importants pour la recherche il y a deux
semaines si les perspectives sont
intéressantes elles sont intempéries
puisque à ce jour la production
d'hydrogène n'en est pas encore au stade
d'un bilan carbone à minima neutre
pouvez-vous nous éclairer merci
la parole est à Francis Dubois
décidément merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre dans votre projet de
loi en accord avec RTE vous prévoyez un
mix énergétique de 50% énergies
renouvelables et 50% nucléaires pour
atteindre les objectifs fixés en matière
de production à l'horizon 2050 pourtant
rien n'est prévu concernant
l'hydraulique alors que le surquipement
électrique est possible sur les rivières
déjà équipées en barrage sur le plan
pragmatique en Corrèze sur la vallée de
la Dordogne le projet d'une station de
pompage site de redonna et qui valent en
production d'une tranche nucléaire est
prêt mais le concessionnaire EDF atteint
la prorogation de la concession depuis
2011 obligation européenne en échange de
réaliser l'investissement
ce projet qui peut être dupliqué et très
pertinent pas d'utilisation d'eau
supplémentaires en vue du réchauffement
climatique car le pompage se fait dans
un virage un barrage existant juste un
marnage important dans ce même barrage
les installations de transport et de
production électrique sont déjà faites
puisqu'il s'agit d'un surréquipement
énergie totalement des carbonée énergie
verte de plus vous savez que la
production hydraulique produit au moment
des pics de consommation donc que
comptez-vous faire pour que ce projet
ces projets puissent se réaliser au plus
vite la parole est à Florence la serre
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre après avoir interrogé
Christophe BECHU la semaine dernière
j'aimerais profiter de votre présence
parmi nous aujourd'hui pour aborder le
sujet de la petite hydroélectricité sur
notre territoire et dans notre mix
énergétique alors que nous demandons aux
Français des efforts sans précédent pour
respecter un principe strict de sobriété
énergétique je suis convaincue
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier qu'il
est notre devoir de porter d'encourager
cette production d'énergie qui est 100%
verte qui renouvelable qui n'aimait pas
de gaz à effet de serre qui fait vivre
économiquement nos territoires et qui
est source d'emploi non délocalisables
tous ces qualités font de la petite
hydro un mode de production d'énergie
très vertueux il est à mon sens urgent
de laisser son potentiel jouer à plein
de porter une politique volontariste de
développement de la petite
hydroélectricité sur nos territoires
madame la ministre quel est votre
position sur ce sujet je vous remercie
la parole est à Hubert hot
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'aimerais tout simplement vous
confier une réalité de terrain qui en
Alsace chez moi se retrouve
régulièrement posée celle des toits
d'église qui orientaient plein Est nous
offre des pans entiers de toiture
conséquente bien exposé au sud et donc à
l'insolation si ceci pouvait être équipé
de panneaux photovoltaïques c'est la
demande de nombreux élus locaux mais qui
se heurtent régulièrement à la vie
défavorable des bâtiments de France et
je pense qu'il est de notre sort de
faire en sorte que ceux-ci soit levés
pour libérer l'envie de nos élus locaux
de nos mères de de permettre une une
nouvelle autonomie énergétique à partir
de ces cœurs de village qui facilement
pourrait équiper nos salles communales
les espaces publics qui entourent
naturellement ces édifices merci merci
chers collègues la parole est à Chantal
Jordan
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je voudrais revenir sur la
réponse donc que vous avez faite par
rapport au plan de sobriété solidaire
que nous avons présenté alors certes il
y a des mesures d'efficacité mais c'est
bien un plan de solidarité de sobriété
et de solidarité sobriété parce que on
fait appel vraiment à la réduction de la
consommation superflue au changement de
comportement et parce que aussi c'est un
plan qui propose de se baser sur les
besoins essentiels voilà et puis c'est
un plan aussi de justice sociale qui
propose donc le partage des richesses
partage des richesses qui doit permettre
de redonner de la dignité à chacun des
citoyens et puis qui vise aussi à
remplacer les mesures de réparation
voilà je vous remercie cher collègue la
parole est à Marie pochon
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous l'avez dit il nous faut
faire des choix pour atteindre les 40%
de réduction de la consommation
énergétique nécessaire pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone maintenir voire
accroître notre consommation énergétique
ou bien nous interroger sur ce qui est
essentiel pour garantir la dignité et
l'émancipation de chacun et chacune et
ce qui est superflu en bref changer les
comportements c'est le sens de la
sobriété madame la ministre vous avez
mentionné lors d'une conférence de
presse en cas de risque
d'approvisionnement et je crois que nous
sommes en plein dedans que vous aviez la
possibilité de commander l'extinction de
tous les écrans publicitaires consommant
chacun l'équivalent d'un ménage français
à l'année mesure également préconisée
par la Convention citoyenne pour le
climat pourquoi ne pas commencer par là
et enfin la parole est à David topiac
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre les objectifs de transition
énergétique sont grande partie tenues
par les collectivités sur le territoire
elles engagé de la planification en
termes de transition énergétique
notamment au travers des plans climats
énergies territoriaux des contrats
d'objectivité territoriaux portés avec
l'ADN aujourd'hui elle se multiplibles
d'un effet ciseaux d'un côté
l'impériosité d'accélérer la transition
énergétique et donc d'investir pour
porter des projets mais de notre côté
faire face à une augmentation de leur
charge de fonctionnement avec un coût de
l'énergie électricité ou gaz qui va
augmenter donc comment comptez-vous les
accompagner et une question qui concerne
également les autorisations que vous
avez évoqué le fait de simplifier des
procédures d'autorisation de déclaration
pour le projet d'énergie renouvelable je
vous alerte sur les difficultés de
travailler avec l'autorité
environnementale qui donne des avis
certes très pertinents mais avec des
délais parfois longs et des
allers-retours incessants qui RA des
projets de 6 à 9 mois et je trouve ce
sujet préoccupant merci
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
vous avez la parole vous répondez comme
vous le pouvez et puis si dans le délai
qui reste vous n'avez pas la possibilité
de répondre à tout peut-être faire des
retours dans un second temps au collègue
madame ad ministre merci beaucoup
s'agissante de l'autoconsommation
collective ça fait partie des sujets qui
ont nous avons intégré dans le grand
plan énergie renouvelable que je
mentionnais qui est à un niveau pour le
coup réglementaire puisque nous avons
pris trois mesures de soutien une prime
à l'investissement qui est versée en une
fois et pas en 5 fois de manière à faire
un peu dans le sens que de vous
mentionnez c'est-à-dire de pas avoir de
reste à charge qui pèse sur les porteurs
de ceux qui qui font cet investissement
la prise en compte de l'inflation dans
le tarif de revente de réseau alors
c'est ça tombe sous le sens mais c'est
quand même mieux de le faire et la
facilitation de schéma
d'autoconsommation ou le producteur
n'est pas le consommateur c'est très
demandé par les collectivités locales et
donc ce texte a été présenté en conseil
supérieur de l'énergie et et
concrétiser
monsieur Guillemard sur ma prime rénove
peut-être pour dire enfin vous avez
plusieurs éléments vous avez l'élément
de des personnes qui sont en situation
de ménage qui sont en situation de
précarité énergétique ceux qui sont en
situation de précarité énergétique ne
sont pas forcément non plus les mieux
outillés la précarité énergétique n'est
pas nécessairement la précarité sociale
néanmoins vous avez un risque de
convergence recouvrement des deux
problématiques et il faut reconnaître
que nos dispositifs primes rénov sont
complexes que si nous avons des
expérimentations ou des mesures pour
financer le reste à charge je pense
notamment à des prêts d'honneur à des
prêts à taux zéro toutes ces sortes de
choses en réalité
abouter l'ensemble de nos mesures pour
aménage qui une situation de précarité
énergétique qui doit en plus faire une
rénovation plutôt approfondie au moins
deux trois quatre gestes signifiants qui
supposent donc de savoir où ils vont
habiter pendant les moments de la
rénovation
ça fait beaucoup de choses donc en fait
on a un vrai sujet d'accompagnement
entre la complexité du montage de
dossier et la réalité du parcours du
ménage pendant cette période de
rénovation thermique et je le dis en
connaissance de cause parce que moi je
suis sur un territoire où on mène
beaucoup de rénovation thermique dans le
logement social donc on a des
appartements
qui permettent de faire des rotations et
néanmoins c'est très compliqué pour les
gens de quitter des maisons enfin c'est
des maisons en réalité de quitter des
maisons dans le bassin minier c'est de
quitter des maisons qu'ils ont habité 40
ans 50 ans ou qui sont des maisons
familiales pour aller habiter même 3 rue
plus loin dans l'appartement dans le
logement de de transition et revenir 6
mois plus tard et ça c'est des réalités
humaines et sociales qui va falloir
prendre en compte alors vous savez que
nous avons déployé des facilitateurs de
ma prime rénove je pense que pour le
coup les collectivités locales au niveau
du bloc communal ont beaucoup aussi à
apporter sur ce sujet là et
effectivement il faut
aller vers une façon d'avoir un reste à
charge zéro d'une manière ou d'une autre
en valorisant les contrats de
performance donc mon premier souci c'est
clairement c'est 12 millions de précares
énergétiques je pense que là il y a un
sujet à prendre à bras le corps
ma prédécesseur enfin la prédécesseur
d'Olivier Klein dans le logement avait
fait beaucoup de choses pour faciliter
massifier accélérer accompagner les
Français dans la rénovation thermique
mais il faut adresser spécifiquement ces
12 millions de précaires énergétiques le
deuxième sujet je vais aller très vite
c'est les rénovations de copropriété le
troisième sujet c'est les rénovations
globales et le quatrième sujet me
semble-t-il d'amélioration c'est comment
on peut peut-être changer les curseurs
de
des aides en fonction de la performance
de la rénovation que l'on suit
avec les années qui suivent et on a un
certain nombre d'outils qui nous
permettent de suivre la réalité de la
performance est-ce que la consommation
d'électricité c'est la consommation de
gaz baisse effectivement parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut arriver à montrer sur
monsieur COS la question des refus
d'offres que vous avez mentionné c'était
tout l'objet de la charte que nous avons
fait signer aujourd'hui au fournisseur
d'énergie et qu'ils ont tous signés
cette charte elle exige que chaque
fournisseur d'énergie face au moins une
offre à son client que cette offre
puisse être alors pour l'année 2023 et
l'État prend une décision qui est
importante c'est qu'elle contre garantit
les risques d'impayés parce que la
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec l'augmentation
très importante des prix le risque
d'impayé est évidemment multiplié à du
concurrence de l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité et donc dans les
analyses ou pricing comme on dit en
mauvais français des offres on incorpore
cette dimension de risque avec des
approches de nature actuelle et donc
c'est ça que nous allons faire baisser
dans les prochaines semaines et qui
devrait faire l'objet d'un amendement au
projet de loi de finance sur la question
des assurances sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques vous n'êtes pas le
premier à me dire je n'ai pas encore la
réponse mais
j'ai chargé mes équipes d'y travailler
monsieur Adam oui le stockage d'énergie
c'est un enjeu et ça va le devenir de
plus en plus à mesure qu'on va
décentraliser d'une certaine manière la
production énergétique et ce qu'il faut
un crédit d'impôt vous savez que je
donc pas toujours très inspiré par les
mécanismes
fiscaux qui s'ajoutent aux autres
mécanismes fiscaux et on sait tous qu'on
faut se battre comme contre notre
tendance naturelle à créer de nouvelles
niches fiscales mais la question doit
effectivement être instruite s'agissant
de l'hydrogène et vous êtes beaucoup à
poser la question je vais donc faire un
point plus général pour Monsieur Buchoux
aussi qui a posé la question de
l'hydrogène et je crois qu'il y a encore
quelqu'un il se reconnaîtra monsieur
Vatin pardon
nous sommes dotés en 2020 d'une
stratégie d'angènes ambitieuse je l'ai
rappelé 9 milliards d'euros ça concerne
l'hydrogène vert c'est à dire d'origine
enfin bas carbone pas seulement vert
c'est important hydrogène bas carbone
c'est-à-dire soit renouvelable soit sur
base nucléaire aujourd'hui cet hydrogène
n'est pas compétitif il est à peu près
trois fois plus cher en termes en coût
de production que l'hydrogène classique
d'où notre plan qui vise d'abord à
mettre en place les briques
technologiques
industrielles de la filière hydrogène
donc ça concerne les piles à combustible
ça concerne les solutions de stockage ça
concerne les électrolyseurs un d'entre
vous à mentionner Life qui fait partie
de ces briques technologiques deuxième
élément accompagner les territoires qui
s'engagent dans des projets hydrogène
j'étais récemment dans l'agglomération
de Dijon qui a par exemple à un projet
complet d'hydrogène à la fois avec la
formation et la recherche académique à
l'Université la dimension
électrolyseurproduction et la dimension
utilisation notamment dans des
utilisations de mobilité transport en
commun pour l'ensemble de
l'agglomération donc on a des plans
complets là qu'on accompagne avec d'adem
et puis nous avons
investi dans un projet important
d'intérêt européen commun qui nous
permet sur
10 projets français sur les 41 projets
sélectionnés ça vous donne quand même
une idée de la part du lion qui a pris
la France dans ce pied
d'accompagner la mise en oeuvre de
l'industrialisation c'est pas seulement
des solutions de R&D c'est
l'industrialisation avec des sites de
production qui répondent à ces
différents enjeux industriels
sur tout alors les batteries électriques
nous avons également un plan matériel
électrique il est un peu plus mature
puisque il a été mis en place à
l'initiative du Président de la
République et de Bruno Le Maire en 2018
il se traduit par 3 giga Factory dans le
nord et le Pas-de-Calais les 3D
Dunkerque Douvrin Douai avec
en amont une un travail qui a été fait
sur les composants des batteries
électriques et sur la question des
matières premières vous savez que je
l'ai porté avec mon autre casquette
précédente casquette au Conseil
Compétitivité européen et que nous avons
avec Thierry Breton notamment travailler
sur un gros matériel acté absolument
nécessaire pour sécuriser aussi les
matières premières et la façon dont ces
matières premières sont extraites et
raffiné pour aller dans les batteries
électriques et on avale toute la
question de la formation et des
compétences notamment avec là aussi un
dispositif de batterie Académie qui a
été lancée avec le vice-président de la
Commission européenne maroche safkovitch
sur et c'est plus de 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissements total
faut que je prenne dans l'ordre sur
Madame
Laurence Maillard mais ignori vous me
permettrez de vous revenir sur les
arrêtés non pris parce que j'avais le
sentiment que les accompagnateurs
étaient bien en place mais
c'est pour septembre 2023 mais
souffle-t-on je vous reviens pour être
plus précise parce que je pense que vous
avez besoin de précision madame brulbois
oui vous avez raison il faut accélérer
les énergies renouvelables vous dire
mieux et vous avez un objet législatif
qui est entre vos mains prochainement
pour le faire et oui vous avez raison il
faut développer les CIC je pense que on
a soutenu des projets dans l'industrie
pour remplacer du charbon par le fond
chaleur et France relance je pense
notamment à ce l'ex usine Solvay à
Dombasle en meurtre et Moselle mais
il y a encore beaucoup à faire sur le
CSR moi j'en suis persuadé
monsieur Buchou je vous ai répondu
monsieur Valence vous avez raison le
covoiturage figure dans le plan sobriété
avec Clément bonne nous ferons des
annonces plus précises demain
permettrait de le faire ensemble puisque
nous y avons travaillé ensemble
Sandrine le fait le faire sur la
grivevoltaïs je crois que ça va être un
bel objet du projet de loi énergie
renouvelable parce que je sais que le
Sénat il travaille je crois savoir même
qu'il y a une BPL qui a été adoptée hier
en
ce matin à l'unanimité donc
nous nous avons affirmé notre position
très ouverte en tant que gouvernement
pour travailler avec le Parlement à la
fois sur la précision de la définition
et sur la volonté de concilier des
enjeux de souveraineté alimentaire qui
sont très claires notamment portées par
les jeunes agriculteurs et les gens jeux
de souveraineté énergétique et je pense
qu'il y a des réponses à ça qui sont des
réponses démontables qui sont des
réponses où on fait attention à ce que
l'agriculteur ne se transforme pas en
producteur d'énergie en premier lieu
mais reste bien agriculteur c'est aussi
la compatibilité avec les aides packs
parce que il nous paraîtrait utile si on
fait des panneaux photovoltaïques
compatibles avec de l'agriculture que
les aides pack demeurent et que ce petit
le fait qu'on la retire ce petit
problème soit levé enfin voilà donc il y
a un certain nombre de sujets mais je
pense que c'est un des beaux objets du
projet de loi accélération des énergies
renouvelables à venir madame cousin et
Monsieur dragon je vais me permettre
d'être très direct
je crois qu'il n'est pas très digne de
la part de représentants élus qui ont
une responsabilité au titre de leur rôle
de député de relayer des fausses
nouvelles ce sont des fausses nouvelles
que vous relayez je vous renvoie
d'ailleurs à RTE il s'agit de ne pas
forcer ce qui n'a rien à voir à bloquer
l'utilisation c'est de ne pas forcer
l'activation des chauffe-eau aux heures
pleines qui est le moment où on en a le
plus besoin et qui est le moment où les
personnes paieraient plus ce qui je
pense paraît de bon sens mais évidemment
je pense que vous connaissez le
fonctionnement d'un chauffe-eau un
chauffe-eau en règle générale il charge
à un moment de la journée et l'eau
chaude est chaude à l'intérieur du
chauffe-eau c'est le principe donc ne
relayez pas ça parce que ce n'est pas
très sérieux et ce n'est pas à la mesure
de la responsabilité que nous avons tous
collectivement
et bien sûr on peut forcer en cas mais
mon Dieu si c'est dans la presse c'est
que c'est vrai
je suis désolé mais la presse a fait la
presse a fait un certain nombre de
checks disant tout à fait le contraire
RTE un communiqué de presse sur le sujet
et donc je me permets de vous renvoyer à
ça puisque c'est dans la presse c'est
aussi dans la presse que c'est faux
voilà donc mais cela traduit une façon
de travailler que je me permets de
souligner au passage
voilà
Monsieur
Madame cousin monsieur Villedieu la
sobriété c'est pas l'arrêt de la
production mais seul briété c'est la
chasse au gaspillage lorsque le
ministère de la transition énergétique
est chauffée à 19 degrés ça n'empêche
pas de produire dans les chaînes de
production je crois qu'il faut être très
clair et je vous remercie là aussi
d'éviter de mélanger les sujets et
vous mentionnez aussi la question du
développement
de voitures électriques notamment et du
besoin de production d'électricité vous
avez raison on va avoir besoin de
produire plus d'électricité mais c'est
pas le même pas de temps
que celui de la crise énergétique des
quatre mois qui viennent je vous rassure
je ne crois pas que les voitures
électriques déployées sur le territoire
vont être multipliés par 10 dans les
quatre mois qui viennent nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui ni la production
disponible ni probablement les moyens
financiers donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une programmation plus réalinelle de
l'énergie qui va permettre effectivement
d'accompagner cette filière et comme le
mentionné monsieur Adam nous rentrons
dans un système énergétique où il y a à
la fois des solutions de stockage de
renvoi de l'énergie et de chargement de
l'énergie qui vont changer notre manière
de piloter le système énergétique je
vais pas revenir sur le véhicule tout
les systèmes de véhicules tout Drid qui
existe aujourd'hui mais qui font partie
des solutions énergétiques du futur
je vous prie de m'excuser pour la
mauvaise prononciation
Fessenheim c'est pas 3000 éoliennes en
fait c'est 300 éoliennes là aussi je
pense qu'il faut être rigoureux dans
l'utilisation
des chiffres vous avez
vous mentionnez que
cette fermeture aurait pu être empêché
la permettrait de vous laisser
interroger la SN la SN
vous indiquera que lorsque
on arrête les maintenances qui
permettent de prolonger la vie d'une
centrale en fait ça prend plusieurs
années à redémarrer puisqu'on fait des
maintenances annuelles mais on fait
aussi dès maintenant triennales
décennales comme vous le savez et donc
lorsque un gouvernement comme en 2012
prend la décision de fermer une centrale
assez logiquement par rapport à cette
décision il va continuer les maintenant
toujours le jour mais il va arrêter les
maintenance de long terme et c'est bien
la situation dans lesquelles était cette
ce réacteur c'est de réacteurs pardon je
vous prie de m'excuser
monsieur Vatin vous posez je vous ai
répondu sur l'hydrogène je vous posez
deux autres questions donc sur le fioul
vous savez que un chèque énergie de
sang de sang à 200 2 0 0
sera envoyé dans les prochaines semaines
à la moitié des ménages qui se ménage
qui se chauffent au fioul donc 50% des
ménages les plus modestes à moitié soit
environ
je pense que le chiffre est là 1,6
millions de foyers c'est pas ça ah oui
si 1,6 millions de foyers c'est ça et en
fait on le fait sur la base de ce que
nous connaissons de la consommation des
Français des années précédentes 200
euros pour les 20% les plus modestes
c'est les deux premiers des cils et 100
euros pour les autres jusqu'au 5e décide
donc les 50% de ménage les plus modestes
et on utilisera les circuits habituels
du chèque énergie puisqu'il fonctionne
bien et qui permettent de payer
directement votre fournisseur de fioul
ou de l'utiliser pour tout autre type
d'énergie si vous êtes chauffé au fioul
mais aussi à autre chose et que vous
avez fait votre remplissage de cuve mais
que vous allez payer vos factures
d'électricité par exemple dans les mois
qui viennent c'est bien sûr complètement
compatible et je veux rappeler aussi
pour les pellets mais c'est valable pour
le fioul que nous avons nous proposons
dans le d'augmenter le
de faire un chèque énergie exceptionnel
pour 40% des ménages qui permettra aussi
non seulement de
financer des dépenses de fioul mais
c'est valable aussi pour lui peler ça
l'était déjà et comme vous le savez la
première ministre souhaite qu'on
travaille sur ce sujet du bois énergie
et des pellets en matière
d'accompagnement des français puisque
vous avez raison de mentionner
l'augmentation des prix nous avons
également travaillé à sécuriser
l'approvisionnement appelée puisque il y
a eu un moment une forte tension sur
cette filière et nous avons accompagné
par des appels à projets la production
française de pellets
monsieur Dubois sur l'hydraulique
donc oui vous avez raison mais je crois
que j'avais répondu déjà un peu à votre
question sur le fait que oui il y avait
du potentiel probablement chez EDF mais
qu'il fallait mettre les choses dans le
bon ordre en revanche ça me permet de
répondre aussi à Madame Lasserre
sur la petite hydroélectricité il y a
deux points d'attention qui sont
importants c'est le conflit des usages
qui est un point qui ressort de plus en
plus fortement et vous savez que
Christophe bichu travaille sur un plan
haut dans un contexte de réchauffement
climatique et c'est mon deuxième point
de vigilance c'est le réchauffement
climatique et le risque d'avoir une
matière première eau qui diminue
structurellement dans les années qui
viennent monsieur hot je note votre
proposition
sur les ABS et en lien avec les églises
c'est vous n'êtes pas le seul à remonter
alors vous le spécifiez par rapport à
l'Alsace et dans un cas qui paraît très
convaincant c'est également un sujet qui
ressorti des discussions un peu
informelles qu'on a pu avoir autour du
projet de loi énergie renouvelable c'est
pas un sujet simple je pense qu'on peut
tous s'accorder sur ça moi je serai
vraiment ravie qu'on trouve des
solutions qui soient équilibrées qui
permettent à la fois de préserver le
patrimoine mais également
de pouvoir avancer avec des solutions et
notamment avec une certaine homogénéité
des solutions sur le territoire parce
que je crois que c'est le point
peut-être le plus
complexe ou en tout cas qui remonte de
la manière la plus forte de dire qu'une
solution à partir de moins on considère
qu'elle est bien appliquée sur
l'ensemble du territoire madame Jourdan
donc je prends votre point
qui plus de l'ordre de l'argumentaire
sur le plan sobriété mais je l'accueille
madame pochon sur l'extinction des
écrans publicitaires vous savez que nous
avons finalisé
le décret mis un peu plus de temps que
prévu en Conseil d'État sur l'extinction
de l'éclairage sur
de nuit nous avons également
effectivement une mesure d'urgence dans
la loi mupa qui permet dans les
situations d'écho wattes rouges de
forcer l'extinction des écrans
publicitaires donc ce sont deux points
qui sont aujourd'hui adressés et nous
avons demandé notamment aux grands
acteurs publics
de
réduire aussi leur empreinte en la
matière alors attention parce qu'il y a
des chiffres qui circulent sur un écran
égal la consommation d'un français c'est
pas tout à fait exact ça dépend de quel
écran ça dépend de
la technologie et là aussi notre réponse
ça sera une réponse qui sera une
combinaison de sobriété d'efficacité
énergétique et je veux préciser une
chose
lorsque j'en discute par exemple avec la
RATP encore une fois l'enjeu pour nous
il y a des mesures symboliques elles
sont importantes elles sont importantes
quand on éteint ça se voit néanmoins il
faut aussi aller au plus efficace et
aujourd'hui pour un acteur comme la RATP
qui a des écrans publicitaires
l'efficacité elle va plutôt être dans la
gestion
des freinages de ces deux véhicules je
veux dire en termes de consommation
d'énergie il n'y a pas d'égal et
l'argent qui rapporte ça régie
publicitaire lui permet d'investir et
d'avoir beaucoup plus d'impact en
matière
d'économie d'énergie donc je sais bien
que ces réponses elles déplaisent parce
que il y a toujours ce goût de la grande
annonce du coup etc moi ma
responsabilité c'est de diminuer
diminuer l'énergie la consommation
d'énergie de le faire durablement donc
oui on le fera mais on fera pas
n'importe quoi et on fera pas des coups
politiques pour pouvoir causer dans le
journal du 20h on le fera parce qu'on
est en responsabilité vis-à-vis des
Français
monsieur taupetiaque simplifié les
autorisations je crois que c'est tout
l'objet
de du projet de loi énergie renouvelable
donc on est à votre disposition
l'autorité environnementale vous savez
qu'elle est indépendante c'est un des
éléments de cycle enfin en tout cas
d'équilibre
et de environnemental qui est important
donc ça je pense que c'est une donnée
d'entrée mais néanmoins ça n'empêche pas
de travailler justement et c'est des
propositions que nous avons mises sur la
table au travers du projet de loi énerv
vous avez une deuxième question mais je
quitter votre première question en fait
oui
alors vous avez plusieurs réponses à ça
et je pense que là aussi le projet de
loi peut être une réponse parce qu'elles
sont pas toujours toutes couvertes à
date c'est peut-être de regarder tout ce
qui est PPA alors avec un vrai
questionnement qui n'est pas simple sur
le traitement de
des investissements d'un côté et des
dépenses de l'autre mais si on pouvait
aller sur des contrats de performance ou
sur la possibilité pour des
collectivités locales et je sais
qu'elles sont plutôt positives par
rapport à ça de pouvoir investir dans
des tranches d'énergie renouvelables qui
leur permettent de sécuriser un coup de
l'électricité ou d'autres enfin du
biogaz le cas échéant si par exemple
elles ont des flottes de véhicules au
biogaz ça peut être des démarches
intéressantes il faut juste être
vigilant à l'impact sur les finances
publiques et qu'on n'est pas quelque
chose qui déforme à contre nos intérêts
puisque là encore notre trajectoire de
finance publique elle doit être je
dirais tenue pour des raisons de
crédibilité financière à un moment on
constate que de tout est en train
d'augmenter dans des pays qui sont moins
rigoureux en matière de gestion publique
je pense notamment à ce qui vient de se
passer au Royaume-Uni mais modulo ça
c'est certainement des pistes
intéressantes et puis vous savez que
avec Christophe Béchu nous portons un
fond vert qui aussi vocation à faciliter
et accompagner les investissements dans
les territoires et que notre objectif
c'est que les investissements se
poursuivent dans les collectivités
locales et qu'on est très conscient que
les situations sont très diverses que
certaines connectivités locales font
effectivement face à une flambée des
prix sur lequel nous travaillons
merci madame la ministre vous avez
répondu point par point à chaque
question un grand merci à vous chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons demain
matin à 8h45 examen en application de
l'article 88 du règlement des
abonnements restants discussion sur la
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre les plastiques dangereux pour
l'environnement et la santé et sur la
proposition de loi adoptée par le Sénat
visant à limiter l'engriègement des
espaces naturels et à protéger la
propriété privée excellente soirée et à
demain matin